Speaker 1: Last week, I told you that
Ukrainian President Volodymyr Zelensky survived
an assassination attempt. There was this unit
of Chechen Special Forces, the Kadyrov ites,
and they had been. They established a plot to
assassinate the Ukrainian President Zelensky.
And we now have learned that there
have actually been three such plots,
which the Ukrainian president has survived.
This is being reported by the New Zealand
Herald and many others Russia, Ukraine, war and
again, it's really Russian invasion of Ukraine.
President Volodymyr Zelensky survives three
assassination attempts in the last week. The
Ukrainian president has reportedly survived three
assassination attempts in the past week alone. The
Times in the UK reports that mercenaries from the
Kremlin backed Wagner Group and Chechen Special
Forces both attempted to kill the president in the
last week, according to reports. The assassination
attempts failed because of subversive anti-war
members within Russia's Federal Security Service,
the FSB, which is the successor to the KGB. Some
elements of the FSB didn't want this to succeed.
They didn't want Zelensky assassinated, and they
alerted Ukrainian officials. Fascinating. The
Ukraine secretary of National Security and defense
has confirmed three foiled assassination attempts.
He told local media he received information from
double agents who do not want to take part in this
bloody war. According to reports, news of one
of the assassination plans sparked the 36 hour
curfew Kiev was under last week so soldiers could
sweep the streets for Russian saboteurs. Civilians
were warned they could be liquidated if they were
spotted outside during curfew, as they would be
assumed to be the enemy. Sources say the Wagner
Group mercenaries have been in Ukraine since
January and are tracking Zelensky and colleagues
via cell phones and then on March one. This is
what I told you last week. A Chechen hit squad
also tried to kill Zelensky, but failed as the FSB
also reported their movements. You know, there's
a couple of interesting things to talk about here
in the last 10 days. Putin says I have no
ill intentions. This is a military operation,
and yet in the last 10 days, Zelensky has survived
three assassination attempts. Russia has bombed
at least one kindergarten, at least one
orphanage, as well as at least one, if not two
nuclear power plants slash sites housing nuclear
reactors. OK, so the framing that we have heard
from the apologists for what Putin is doing as
a very limited military operation? Those can go.
In the toilet, the same place Trump puts his
documents, right? But in all seriousness,
it's impossible to even imagine what Zelensky
and his family are going through right now. And
the very interesting thing, you know, later we're
going to talk about Lindsey Graham talking about
assassinating Vladimir Putin, but yet we've had
actual assassination attempts against the Lenski.
I believe that if Putin were assassinated,
that would cause a collapse to this entire
this entire invasion, but not the other way.
And what I mean by that is as follows Ukrainians
actually understand what's going on. They
understand that Putin has invaded. They understand
what they're fighting for. And while Zelensky
is the leader, the movement to defend Ukraine
and resist Russian invasion would continue even
if Zelensky were killed. If Zelensky were killed,
they're still going to do everything they're
doing to repel Russia. Maybe even bolstered.
OK. That's what would happen if
Zelensky were killed. On the other hand,
many Russian troops and even some Russian generals
don't seem to think this is a particularly good
idea the invasion of Ukraine. They don't
even know what they're fighting for. We
have incredible video from a captured P.O.W.
Russian troop who was like, I don't know,
we were told all this stuff we got here. It's not
even really true. It's crazy. If Putin did die,
the invasion would almost immediately end,
whereas killing Zelensky won't actually have
that effect. Let me know your thoughts. Find
it! Find me on Twitter at De Packman. We'll
take a quick break. As many of you have no doubt
by now heard, we are an independent media program,
we depend on your support to do what we do to do
the podcast, the YouTube channel, the TV show,
the radio show, all of it. And I would love it if
you signed up for a membership at join Packman dot
com. These are very cheap memberships, and they
come with great perks. Perks of great strength,
one might say, including access to the Daily
Bonus Show. Sign up at join Packman dot com.